look at them  it's like throwback Thursday in their  gladiator reunion this is good this is  so good this is good would it be good  can't let it be good if it's not good in  that it's not good that looks good but  that is not good trust me so we are  agreed that until Hollis Doyle goes down  no more campaigning against each other  Mellie backs up see Susan backs off of  Mellie we can do that we could do this  start gathering until I need something  lethal  I'm Susan what about the cease fire  cease fires get broken I want to make  sure we're protected don't even it can  still be good there's time okay I'm  never gonna be what they were quick deep  down Abbey is one of us it can still be  good